mine's in North Dakota I graduated
college last year I'm debt-free I bring
on thirty five thousand a year I'm not
sure what my next step would be they'll
focus on giving saving for a house or
investing yes you get on every dollar
calm to get your budget going Brian and
if you're debt-free your first goal is
to build an emergency fund of three to
six months of expenses then after that
if you want to save for a home save up a
downpayment in the next couple of years
before you start your long term
investing that's a the place to do it is
between the emergency fund and the long
term investing if you want to take a
little longer to save up the downpayment
then you would go ahead and start your
baby step four which is 15 percent of
your income going into retirement as far
as giving goes I'm an evangelical
Christian which means that I give a
tithe a tenth of my income and the tithe
by definition is off the top before you
do anything else so I give ten percent
of my income to my local church before I
do any other things then I work on some
of my personal financial goals that God
has told me to do which is to save and
to take care of my own household and do
those kinds of things invest long-term
in the house of the wise or stores of
choice food and oil so we invest a
foolish man devours all he has so we
don't spend everything we make stay out
of debt because the borrower is slave to
the lender and I take care of my own
householder and worse than an unbeliever
I make sure that the emotional and basic
needs and that includes some emotional
needs in other words of my 25 year
anniversary I take my wife on a cruise
that's not taking care of my household
that kind of thing is in the budget and
and then once I'm a debt free and I
start my emergency funds above the tithe
I'll do some other giving those are
called offerings and those are more
optional the tithe is your minimum
standard for those of us that are people
of faith now some people believe that
people don't believe that but if you
don't believe that you're just wrong
there you go
so anyway that's how it works and that's
what I do and so all the while my budget
is operating at ninety percent to do all
those other goals to build the emergency
fund to build the down payment to get
15% going into retirement and the weird
thing is is that generous people have a
much higher tendency to prosper you know
I haven't talked about that in a while
we cover that in the book the legacy
journey the generous people i when you
give money away intentionally and
steadily as a part of who you are as a
person and you're not willy-nilly about
it you're not just throwing money out
the car window as you're driving along I
mean you're careful and you're wise
about your giving and your you're not
giving a drunk a drink we're not doing
that kindly but we're supporting things
that help and love on people and you
help and love on people so your church
or local homeless shelter whatever it is
like that it's being run properly when
you give money away it changes not them
but you it's very difficult to find
someone who consistently gives week
after week after week after week who has
the same level of marriage problems as
someone who does not give the reason is
is that makes you a less selfish person
automatically when you give you don't
become a less selfish person and then
give you give and it makes you it breaks
and reforms your heart every time you
give and so you're less selfish and less
selfish people are just better husbands
they're better wives oh by the way
they're better employees I mean you got
two guys standing in front of you one of
them is a selfish jerk and the other one
is a generous person not on about their
wallets something about the way they act
because generous is more than just your
wallet generous is the guy who holds the
door when you got a bag full of
groceries generous is the one that runs
over and helps you pick up the groceries
when the bottom falls out of the bag and
your stuffs rolling all over the parking
lot of the grocery store that's the
generous and you know what's weird if
you were to if you were to have 10
people run over and help someone that
poop the bottom fell out of the grocery
bag get 10 people and you interviewed
them I mean all things being equal
location of town and all that kind of
stuff but just in general you're going
to find that
wealthy people have more of a tendency
to run over and do that that's why
they're wealthy because when someone's
more generous people just like having
you around as a person and you have a
tendency to get promotions you got two
guys stand in front of you one of yous a
selfish jerk one of them's a generous
person you know you own the business I'm
gonna give you the generous person why
because he's going to be leading or
she's going to be leading other people
in the organization and they're gonna
like working for that person they're
gonna work harder and work better they
don't work for Simon Legree with his
whip out Chuck such no I wants to work
for that that's not a leader that's a
boss and there's a difference leaders
know how to serve inherent and serving
is a level of generosity and it's a
level of humility realizing the Nexus
the world doesn't run through the top of
your dadgum head so all of that enters
into this equation of when you give you
have a very practical tendency to
prosper because you're just more
attractive generous people are
attractive people and not because you're
going to give you money but they're just
attractive people they're they're more
likable people and so they get offered
deals they could offer to be put in
stuff they're their opinion is asked
more often they're they're more pleasant
and conversation everything about their
lives is better and it really goes back
to our generous and some generosity that
that's why you know I'm sure as a
Christian that's why God put generosity
in the Bible he says forgive give 1/10
regularly give give give give and
there's all these aunt tons hundreds of
scriptures talking about giving and it's
not because like God needs your money he
doesn't need your money if he wanted
your money he would just take it there
be a greasy spot where you're sitting
he's God he doesn't need your money and
I'm doing God a favor really give me a
break he set the son in place okay I
don't think he needs your two dollars
that ministry wouldn't be there than for
me now you really are confused
that's not generosity that's
manipulation so he has us to give he
gives all this instruction in scripture
on giving
because of what it does inside of us his
goal is not to move economics around his
goal is to change your heart and make
you into a generous person which is just
a whole lot more loveable likeable
attractive person there's nothing uglier
than selfishness it's just ugly you GL y
ugly and you run into it I mean you run
into it with wealthy people you run into
it poor people all those rich people are
greedy no no they're not some of our
some of our jerks but most of them I
know really good folks and it's one of
the reasons they're wealthy they work
their tail end off and they're generous
a kind and they serve in the community
they provide a service to the community
and that's how where their wealth come
from it didn't because they stole from
somebody wasn't cuz they ripped somebody
off cause they were greedy now there's a
certain number of those out there but I
mean as many greedy poor people as I do
and the hilarious thing is I mean a lot
of people have all this philosophical
insight on money and don't have any
money that is I mean that's like asking
a fat person how to get skinny that's
ridiculous
you're broke I don't need your opinion
on money you're 500 pounds I don't need
your opinion on weight loss I'm not mad
at you
but in or a different field for God's
sakes we don't care what your opinion is
because it's not working for you so
you've been married 16 times I hope this
one sticks but don't write a book on
marriage nobody wants to read it and all
the things I learned in my 16 marriage
is what can be a break you and learn
anything we need to stay away from you
is what we need to do it when it comes
to marriage now I love you you be my
friend we'll go out to dinner have a cup
of coffee but I'm not doing that for
your marriage advice when it comes to
marriage you're stupid
I'll need your input on that so find
people that are winning and look at what
they're really doing not what the news
is saying not what political correctness
is saying not what some politician is
saying but look what real people are
doing and I'll tell you I'm at thousands
and thousands and thousands of
millionaires and 30 years of doing this
and the vast majority north a 90% one of
the things they attribute their wealth
to is generosity this is the Dave Ramsey
show hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show so you have to break the cycle
you have to flip this thing on its head
and make it behave you've got to get so
fired up and wired up that you're broke
friends think you've lost your mind